President Trump is looking for his
fourth national security adviser in less
than three years after John Bolton left
the White House yesterday the president
tweeted he disagreed strongly with
Bolton and asked him to step down after
17 months now Bolton says he offered to
resign Paula Reid is at the White House
to sort it all out Paul it sounds like a
big old he said he said was John Betsy
pushed out that's exactly what it is
that he said he said but source close to
Bolton though says he delivered this
resignation letters much shorter than
some we've seen in the past but in
speaking with current and former
administration officials it's clear
Bolton committed what is considered a
cardinal sin at the Trump White House
when he tried to run things his own way
the president's entitled to the staff
that he wants president Trump's quest to
get what he wants has caused
unprecedented turnover at the National
Security Council burning through three
national security advisors in less than
three years more than any other
president in history Iran is a rogue
regime both news critics pointed to his
hawkish worldview his agenda was regime
change and war now the president has one
less voice discouraging his outreach to
foreign adversaries I have a very good
relationship with Chairman Kim Kim
jong-un while Bolton was especially
disliked by the North Korean regime he
and the president also clashed over how
to proceed in Afghanistan with Bolton
opposing a planned meeting with Taliban
at Camp David I took my own advice I
like the idea of meeting and he was
famously skeptical of Iran while the
president has signaled an openness to
restarting talks with the regime if the
circumstances were correct toward the
right I would certainly agree to that
but CBS News has learned the final
breaking point came from reports that
President Trump wanted to deploy nuclear
weapons against hurricanes mr. Trump
denied the story but believed both
leaked it and was furious I'll leave to
the President to talk about the reasons
he made decision top administration
officials didn't appear sad to see
Bolton go and shrugged off the turmoil
I'm never surprised
even with all the turnover amid the
president's senior staff his approach to
foreign policy has remained pretty much
the same though it is expected that
Bolton's departure will make it easier
to engage with Tehran now until a
successor is named the deputy national
security adviser Charles Kupperman will
step in for Bolton Anthony Paula thank
you glad to see a little landscaping
going on there White House this morning
and I must say that ambassador Bolton's
letter resignation was admirably concise
his English teacher would be very proud
no Paula was appalled it was very
diplomatic in her description with one
sentence I resigned effectively
immediately when she said it's a little
shorter than once in the back